I think when 8th grade girls hear the term engineering,...
...it's a very broad term that they may not fully understand and so being able to come here...
...and meet engineers and be able to have the hands-on experience...
...where they can see and learn everything that encompasses engineering is very beneficial.
To inspire these young minds, we're giving them an opportunity...
...to really understand what's possible.
They're gonna learn to do in this activity,...
...it's a very hands-on activity that they're doing today.
They're gonna make mistakes and that's okay.
Because in engineering, sometimes we don't get it right the first time.
We would love to have it right the first time all the time, but sometimes we don't.
But you learn from it and that's what's important...
...is that you go through the process of thinking about, "What's the problem I'm gonna solve?"
"How do you solve it?"
You work in a team environment that allows you to...
...talk and work with other people who will help solve your problems.
You don't have to do it by yourself.
They're thinking of new problems, they want new capabilities.
They're our future engineers.
I saw a lot of excitement from the girls when they were putting the hands together,...
...and seeing their hands on, seeing them putting the little pieces together.
And mostly when they saw the finished product and actually could see...
...how the hand works and how it can benefit a person.
I just want to thank Rockwell Collins for allowing us to come...
...and allowing us to be a part of such a cool event that the kids can experience.
And again, just have that hands-on experience and meet the engineers,...
...to get excited and be inspired to possibly become an engineer.